oh hey what's up thank you under your
name it says crude too by the way have
you seen FINA I think he came this way
oh not a traitor always a traitor do
like I said it I think seananners is the
traitor where's this game ever
your tone really said like I got him now
and donate whatever you want his accents
so cute when he says yeah sure he's like
donate to my nice charity it's so cute
while sitting in his chair making his
chili accents no he doesn't say what say
ninja yeah get over here like it's
because they're already here or any
cries it really tries the trick and I
put down my mom oh he wasn't the traitor
okay I'm still innocent thank you what's
the call here Martin what do we do yeah
what do we do Mike
[Laughter]
the whole internet if I look at my file
it says that that [ __ ] you saying every
time I did this corrupt and then deletes
it we were having our standoff up here
and you ruined it I was just proving my
innocence that's good you should do by
filling yourself okay it's the only way
you can yell oh wow well really strong
like scary that was like inception twice
[Music]
lower the risk happened folder oh god
right behind you can just in case know
dare you shoot me in the back like that
I know the hell you gained her trust in
everything I never trust
[Music]
[Applause]